-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Yeah, enjoy yourself. Welcome.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, this is fun --
over the weekend,
the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree
arrived in New York City.
This is real. Can we see it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hm.
[ Laughter ]
-The what?
-They never look as good as
they do in their dating profile.
You know what I'm saying?
Don't worry.
They're trying to turn the tree
so the giant gap faces the wall.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Let's get to some news.
On Saturday, former president
Trump's youngest daughter,
Tiffany,
got married at Mar-a-Lago.
Yeah, the cutest part
of the wedding
was when Eric Trump
carried the ring down the aisle
on a tiny pillow.
It was very cute.
And there was a special moment
when Trump was like,
"Well, if I'm giving kids away,
will someone take Don Jr.?"
Of course, everyone was talking
about the reception
when Tiffany threw the bouquet
and Melania elbowed
six other women to catch it.
And you go,
"Wait a minute. No."
The only issue at the wedding --
they were supposed to have
a ton of seats,
but somehow Trump lost them all.
[ Laughter ]
-Ohh! Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause ]
-Yep, Tiffany Trump
got married at Mar-a-Lago,
and I don't know how this
happened, but we got our hands
on a recording of Trump's
"father of the bride" speech.
-Wow.
-Yeah, listen to this.
[Jimmy as Pres. Trump] Forgive
me. I'm gonna read my toast.
[ Clears throat ]
Aww. That was so sweet.
That's so nice.
[ Applause ]
Switching gears, President Biden
just arrived in Bali
for the G20 summit.
And when he landed, he received
an extra-special greeting.
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I can't tell whether Biden's
happy, confused, or both.
[ Laughter ]
He's like...
Meanwhile, today in Bali,
Biden held his first
in-person meeting
with Chinese President Xi
since taking office,
and it lasted three hours.
For both men, the hardest part
was pretending that they didn't
hack the other person's e-mails
to see what they'd say.
Yeah.
That's right.
Biden and Xi met in person
for the first time
since Biden took office,
and their first handshake
was captured in a video.
Check this out.
[ Young-Holt Unlimited's
"Soulful Strut" plays ]
♪♪
Wow. Amazing moment.
That's -- Wow.
-Wow!
-I think it went well.
Some more big political news.
Over the weekend,
Democrats learned that they'd
won control of the Senate.
Yep. For breaking news...
[ Cheers and applause ]
For the breaking-news alert,
MSNBC played...
[ Rasta horn blares ]
While Fox News played...
[ Sad trombone plays ]
Yeah.
Democrats are giving credit
to Gen Z,
who really showed up to vote.
Republicans were like, "How did
Gen Z vote for Democrats?
All we were trying to do was
stop student-loan forgiveness."
In other political news,
I saw that Mark Kelly
defeated Blake Masters
in Arizona.
But --
-I did -- I did what?
-What?
-Did you say my name?
-I'm sorry, Mark. I was talking
about Mark Kelly, the Senator,
not Mark Kelley from The Roots.
You have the same name.
-Oh, my bad.
This happens a lot.
People get us mixed up
constantly.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
I'll show you what I mean
in a new segment called
"Mark Kelly or Mark Kelley?"
-♪ Is it Mark Kelly
or Mark Kelley? ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-You guys wrote
an intro song for this?
-Okay, let's take a look
at the differences
between Mark Kelly
and me, Mark Kelley.
First up, Mark Kelly
is an astronaut.
Meanwhile, Mark Kelley
is a sick-ass bassist.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-When did you make all --
When did you make
all these graphics?
-Up next,
Mark Kelly has a twin brother.
Meanwhile, Mark Kelley
is a sick-ass bassist.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Please stop saying "sick-ass."
-Jimmy, stop interrupting me!
It's very rude!
-You interrupted me.
-It's my time to shine.
Everyone's been talking
about this cool,
bald astronaut senator
with my name,
and I'm tired of it.
I've always been
the cool Mark Kelley,
and now this dude comes along
and steals my thunder.
I'm hurt. And I'm scared.
And I'd appreciate it
if you'd let me have this
one tiny thing, okay?!
-Geez, I'm sorry, Mark.
I didn't realize you were
so upset about it. Go ahead.
-Thank you. Up next,
Mark Kelly lives in Arizona.
While Mark Kelley
is a sick-ass bassist.
-Alright. Come on.
You can't just keep saying that.
-You know what?
-What?
-I don't have to put up
with this. I'm out of here.
Who's with me?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who's with him?
Who's with him?
The real Mark Kelley, everybody.
He'll come back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Who's with me?"
This is going viral --
On Friday night,
during a live
college basketball game,
the camera caught a fan
who looked like
he was showing off
his Costco membership card.
Check this out.
-That was Raymie Styons
who got the foot stepped on,
Bill Covington...
[ Laughter ]
-He was like -- He was like,
"Yeah, I don't want to brag,
but I can buy 64 rolls
of paper towels at once,
anytime I want!"
I like how
she turns it over, right?
She's like, "Maybe there's
something impressive
on the other side,"
and she's like...
Well, get this,
a man in the U.K.
thought he was
losing his hearing
and then discovered
that part of an ear bud
had been stuck in his ear
for five years.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
After doctors removed it,
he was like, "Thanks.
I've had that song
stuck in my head since 2017."
And finally, in Arizona,
two teachers
who are husband and wife
were fired after students
found their OnlyFans account.
They would've been sent
to detention,
but that's actually
how one of their videos started.
When asked to comment,
they were like,
"You know, if you paid teachers,
we wouldn't have to do this."
Guys, I saw that in 2024,
the Summer Olympics --
they just unveiled their mascot.
And it is a hat.
Here it is.
This is it.
Look, kids, it's a hat,
just like every Olympic athlete
has never worn.
Yeah. Can we see it again?
Honestly,
the only thing that mascot
doesn't look like is a hat.
It looks like
a holiday-themed poop emoji.
-Oh!
-Well, speaking of red hats,
everyone is talking about this.
Earlier tonight,
former president Trump
officially announced that he's
running for president in 2024.
[ Audience groans ]
You guys saying "Bruuuce"?
[ As Trump ]
They're saying "Bruuuce."
Springsteen's on --
Springsteen's on "Fallon."
[ Normal voice ] Yep, Trump
made the big announcement
from Mar-a-Lago,
or, as it's also known,
the summer home of
the National Archives.
I'm pretty sure this is
the first presidential campaign
to be kicked off
from an active crime scene.
Seriously, was the set from
"Dahmer" not available?
What's...
[ As Trump ] It's the number-1
show on Netflix.
[ Normal voice ]
Guys, listen to this.
Fox News founder Rupert Murdoch
reportedly told Trump
that he will not back his
2024 White House bid.
Apparently, Rupert Murdoch
isn't supporting Trump
because he prefers Ron DeSantis.
Ironically,
that's the first time Trump
was the one to get dumped
for someone younger.
Yep, Murdoch
is breaking away from Trump,
so now they're going to set
Sean Hannity
in the middle of the room
and see which one he goes to.
It's like, "Come here.
Come here, boy.
Come here. Come here, boy!
Come on.
Remember who raised you."
That's right -- Trump's running
for president yet again in 2024.
And Trump says that he's still
at the top of his game,
feeling sharper than ever and
totally 100% ready to lead...
-The United Schess.
-He said that he won't be
slowed down by what happened
in last week's...
-Midtown and midturn...
-...election. He's ready to
restore his standing
among all of our elected...
-Lawmarkers.
-He wants to fix our broken...
-Supply chair.
-And work with
big business leaders like...
-Tim Apple.
-He won't be bogged down
by attacks
from unknown sources that are...
-Anonomiss.
Really, anomanous.
-Because he'll fight
for this country
until we're
all back to saying...
-Merry Chrissus, everybody.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Still got it. Close. Almost.
Meanwhile, today, Mike Pence
released his new memoir,
"So Help Me God."
Here's the book. Yeah. Yeah.
So, if you're dreaming of
a really white Christmas,
have I got the gift for you.
Yep, Mike Pence's new memoir
was just released,
and we actually got our hands
on the audio book.
-Really?
-Yeah. Listen to this.
-Wow!
-Hey, here's some
big music news.
Today's nominations
were announced
for the 65th Annual
Grammy Awards,
which will take place
in February
at the Crypto.com Arena.
I think during the 75th Grammys,
we're all gonna be laughing
that it used to be called the
Crypto.com Arena.
That's right -- the Grammys will
be at the Crypto.com Arena.
Then they're having
the after party at
the Dogecoin Theater.
Honestly, the Crypto.com Arena
makes sense,
because most of the nominees
will walk away with nothing.
[ Cymbal crash ]
Some more entertainment news.
I heard that the Season 5
premiere of "Yellowstone"
had a record-breaking
12.1 million viewers.
The show is a massive hit, and I
think it's already influencing
some of the programming on TV.
Look at how they updated
"A Charlie Brown Thanksgiving."
-Oh, Charlie Brown!
♪♪
Come on, Charlie Brown.
I'll hold the ball,
and you kick it.
-Listen up, woman.
If you pull away that football,
I'll bury your ass alive in
a pile of horse[bleep]
-You see what I'm saying?
Something's...
-Wow! Just a little.
-It just seems different.
Well, I saw an ad
for a new Teddy bear
that just hit the market.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
-It's the perfect
holiday gift for someone
who just wants a hug.
This is an
emotional-support Teddy bear,
and, as you can see,
it's about the actual size of an
actual person -- 5'7".
You can even dress it up
and change its clothes,
and it's 160 bucks.
[ Laughter ]
-You can order one online
or buy one at Build-A-Boyfriend.
Well, this is going viral.
A man in China ran a full
marathon in a pretty unique way.
Check this out.
-If the thought of running
a marathon has you winded,
imagine doing it while smoking
a pack of cigs.
He completed all 26.2 miles in
3 hours and 28 minutes.
-Wow! This guy's a legend.
He's already on the front of
the box of Wheezies.
I don't know
if you guys saw this,
but for the last 24 hours,
#RIPJimmyFallon
has been trending on Twitter.
Yeah. Even worse,
when they heard I died,
Ticketmaster kicked me out of
line for Taylor Swift tickets.
And I go, "This is terrible.
This is awful."
Right after it happened, though,
I was so touched that NBC
immediately called and asked,
"How can we turn this into
another 'Law & Order'?"
And I go, "What?"
Yeah, #RIPJimmyFallon was
the number-2 trend on Twitter.
I tried everything I could
to bump it down.
I even tried the hashtag
#RIPPEDJimmyFallon
I thought that would maybe help.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to
the number-1 trending topic.
Everyone's talking about this.
Last night,
former president Trump
announced that he's running
for president in 2024.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
When I heard Trump
was running again,
I said, "Over my dead body."
Yeah.
-Hey-oh!
♪♪
-That's right -- Trump's
running for a third time.
Here he is making the
announcement from Mar-a-Lago.
-In order to make America
great and glorious again,
I am tonight announcing
my candidacy for
President of the United States.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know we are, but why does he
seem like he's already over it?
What a moment.
You can really feel the
indictment -- I mean excitement.
Yep, Trump wants to make America
"great and glorious again,"
or as it will now be known,
MAGAGA.
[ As Trump ] Lady MAGAGA.
Itchy gichy ya MAGAGA.
[ Normal voice ] As always,
Trump covered a lot of ground
during his speech,
and he even gave
a shout-out to his son Eric.
Watch this.
-My one boy -- Stand up, Eric.
I think he got more subpoenas
than any man in
the history of our country.
So unfair.
Al Capone.
You all heard
of the great gangster?
Al Capone got far less.
Eric Trump got more subpoenas.
He's a PhD in subpoenas.
And I appreciate the job you do
and the abuse that you've taken.
-Whoa.
-It's ironic,
because at Trump University,
you can actually get a PhD
in subpoenas.
He's like, "That's Eric.
He's got that
big subpoenas energy."
Yeah, but Trump was advised
to speak for only 45 minutes,
but he went on for over an hour.
In fact, Trump rambled on
for so long
that even Fox News
cut away from the speech.
That's real.
The relationship
has gotten so bad,
"Fox & Friends" now say they're
just "Fox & Acquaintances."
Some more political news.
Today, Senator Mitch McConnell
was re-elected
as Senate minority leader,
beating Florida Senator
Rick Scott.
Can we see McConnell and Scott?
Yeah, it's the first time the
tortoise has beat the no-hair.
[ Cymbal crash ]
Well, switching gears,
as I mentioned earlier,
Taylor Swift tickets
went on presale yesterday,
and there was such high demand
that Ticketmaster crashed.
Everyone was
furious at Ticketmaster,
so they posted
this message basically just
telling people to be patient.
Be patient.
Obviously,
that didn't go over well.
So then Ticketmaster
posted more updates.
First, there's...
That's not going to help.
Then there was...
Then they said...
Yeah. Then they said...
And finally...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's not helpful.
Hey, get this.
In response to Costco's
$1.50 hot-dog-and-drink combo,
Sam's Club is now offering
the same meal for $1.38.
Meanwhile, 7-Eleven is like,
"If you're brave enough
to eat our hot dogs,
we'll pay you $1.50."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, finally,
according to UN estimates,
the world population reached
8 billion people this week.
That's a huge milestone.
The UN actually released
all sorts of data
about the population, and it's
pretty interesting to see.
Let's take a look.
When it comes to the global
population...
[ Applause ]
Check out some more data here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's another one.
I'm 6'7".
Next up...
[ Laughter, applause ]
And, finally...
Well, guys,
it is the holiday season,
but, apparently, not everyone
is feeling so festive.
CNN just announced
that they're no longer
allowing their anchors to drink,
on- or off-camera,
during the network's
New Year's Eve coverage.
[ Booing ]
-Come on.
-When they heard that,
Andy Cohen and Anderson Cooper
were like,
"Okay, edibles, it is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's it. You said it."
-Yes!
-That's right,
no drinking on New Year's Eve.
At that point, it's not a party.
It's just a news channel
filming a clock.
[ Laughter ]
Do you know what I'm saying?
Seriously, why would CNN mess
with the one night
people actually watch CNN?
I don't know why they --
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of CNN, last night,
they hosted a town hall
with former vice president
Mike Pence.
And, ironically,
it had all the excitement
of a sober New Year's Eve party.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, no drinking on New Year's
and a Mike Pence town hall.
It explains why they just
changed their slogan to...
[ Laughter ]
CNN hosted a town hall
with the former vice president,
and I noticed that Pence
has some trouble
remembering everyone's name.
Take a look at this.
Watch this.
-Meet Andrea Barber-Dansby
from Anderson, Indiana.
-Andrea.
-Hi, Barbara.
-Hello.
-Barbara, thank you.
I represented Madison County
in Congress for many years.
-Andrea.
[ Laughter ]
-It's nice to see you.
-Daniela Moloci.
She's from Fort Wayne.
-Oh, Michele, uh,
good to have you here.
-And --
-Daniela, Daniela.
-Danielle, forgive me.
We have a process
in this country
where states conduct
elections, Jack.
Jake.
[ Laughter ]
-I guess now we know why he
calls his wife Mother, you know?
-Hey!
-Okay.
[ Laughter, oohs, and applause ]
Don't worry.
He'll be fine,
once someone updates
his operating system.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and, throughout
the hour-long town hall,
Pence seemed pretty intent
on promoting his new book.
Watch this.
-I appreciate you reading
my book.
And I write about that
in my book.
As I write in my book...
As I wrote in my book...
And as I recount in the book...
As you read in my book...
I was actually there,
as I write in my book...
As I write in my book...
And in my book...
In the back of my book...
As I said at the close
of my book...
I write about in my book...
When I sat down
to write my book...
You can see the picture
in my book.
Let me say,
as I said in my book...
which I appreciate you reading.
[ Laughter ]
-I did.
-Wow!
By the end, Pence was just
answering every question like,
"Well, book.
That's a very good book.
I booked to that book.
You book?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Some more political news.
Everyone's talking about this.
More than a week
after the midterms,
Republicans finally won control
of the House.
On the bright side, it's nice
to see them seizing the House
without zip ties
and a Viking helmet.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
[ Whistling ]
Republicans are still fighting
over why they couldn't get
a few more seats.
They don't know if they should
blame Trump, McConnell,
or Ticketmaster.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, today,
Speaker Nancy Pelosi announced
that she is stepping down as the
House Democratic leader.
Pelosi, who's 82, said it's time
for a new generation to lead.
And then Biden was like,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa-kay, Nancy.
Ha ha ha ha. She's funny.
Take her home. Take her home.
Ha ha, she's so funny."
Pelosi served as speaker
with presidents Bush, Obama,
Trump, and Biden,
or, as she called them,
the reason why she started
smoking, quit,
then started again,
then quit again.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did You guys see this?
For the first time, the FDA has
approved a lab-grown meat
for human consumption.
The FDA was like, "Don't worry.
It's completely safe.
Disgusting, but safe."
-Yeah.
-Some business news --
Frontier Airline
is now selling something called
the Go Wild annual pass,
which offers unlimited flights
for a year.
It's funny because Go Wild
is also the name
of Southwest's boarding process.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a new poll found
that 40% of people think
Amazon has the most attractive
delivery drivers.
-Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
-That's why no one cares
when they show up
like your package has arrived
and they're not
holding anything.
Guys, it's Friday.
I'm in a great mood.
Unlike Twitter,
we made it to the weekend.
You know, and I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you see this?
After more than
1,000 key employees resigned,
Twitter closed
all of their offices.
And, apparently,
due to the mass resignations,
the platform could start
breaking soon.
Even crypto was like, "Damn.
That came crashing down fast."
Right now, things are so bad,
Twitter recommends
writing your tweet on
a piece of paper
and just mailing it to
all of your followers.
Yeah, a ton of employees quit
after Elon asked them
to commit to an extremely
hardcore work environment.
Staff was like, "If I'm going to
go extremely hardcore
for an app,
I don't want Twitter money.
I want OnlyFans money."
♪♪
-Twitter.
-Last night, things got so bad,
the hashtag #RIPTwitter
started trending.
I just want to say, I died on
Twitter before it was cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No big deal.
♪♪
Some people say
the chaos at Twitter
could lead to a comeback
for Tumblr.
That'd be fun to
get my political news
at the same place I used to post
my Urkel fan fiction.
I think that'd be fun.
Yeah, Twitter's not
looking so great right now,
and I think some other companies
are trying to take advantage.
Check out this.
I saw this today.
-Twitter is
an absolute disaster,
a horrible company that's
terribly run in every way.
So when thinking of us,
remember, there's worse.
-I go, "Oh, now I get it. Yeah.
Now I get it."
Some news from Washington.
Tomorrow, President Biden's
granddaughter
is getting married on the
South Lawn of The White House.
That's nice. It's interesting.
To RSVP, you had to check
"yes" or "Ivanka."
Not gonna show up, no.
Biden's already emotional.
It's the first time an
80-year-old has ever said,
"Get on my lawn.
The South Lawn."
It's different getting married
when your grandfather's
president, though.
You get cards that say,
"Enjoy the panini maker,
love Kim Jong-un."
Yeah, the Biden family has
a lot to celebrate this weekend,
'cause on Sunday,
the president turns 80.
Wow.
Just to give you a sense of
how old that is, consider this.
He's 80.
Democrats don't want to
take any chances,
so there are going to be
no surprise parties.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't clap too loud.
He might be watching.
Hey, this is big.
Today, the Justice Department
named a special counsel
to investigate whether
former president Trump should be
charged for January 6th
or taking classified documents.
As we speak, Trump is squeezing
into a turkey costume
to trick Biden
into pardoning him.
[ As Trump ] Gobble, gobble.
Gobble, gobble.
[ Normal voice ] Switching
gears. Some big sports news.
This weekend,
the World Cup begins in Qatar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep. Soccer is huge
across the world.
Meanwhile,
Americans are like, "Wait.
'Ted Lasso'
is based on a real sport?"
Disney, I saw
that they just filed a patent
for a new type of
roller coaster,
and it looks pretty crazy.
Watch this.
-Walt Disney just filed a patent
for a roller coaster
that jumps the track?
Engineers say it has to move
at precise speed
every single time,
which can easily be impacted by
the weather, by humidity,
number of riders,
and many, many other elements.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-The ride is called You First.
[ Cymbal crash ]
Don't worry -- they're going to
put some pillows
down the first few times they
try it, so it should be alright.
It's the only ride
with a sign that says,
"You must be this tall to die."
But this is nice.
Disney takes your picture
during the ride,
and a crime-scene photographer
takes it after.
"Jumps the tracks."
Meanwhile,
Six Flags was like, "Big deal.
We've been doing that
for years."
Get this -- the makers of
Scrabble have announced
that they now will accept
hundreds of new words.
-Oh!
-Check out this commercial they
just released.
-America's most beloved
board game is better than ever,
with hundreds of
new playable words, like...
And to make it even more fun,
we now accept misspelled words,
made-up words, and tater tots.
-Interesting, right?
-Wow!
Wow! Indeed.
-Also, I read that Tyson Foods
recalled 94,000 pounds
of ground beef
'cause it may contain
a hard, mirror-like substance.
They're really bending over
backwards to avoid saying,
"Fine, it's glass, okay?"
A "mirror-like substance"?
Nothing worse than eating
a 1-pound burger
and catching
a glimpse of yourself.
"Ugh! That's what I look like?"